hey there again get your old pals uncle
Hank and Kippy we got some big news
folks are you garbage is coming to the
gas digital network that is correct to
me an old Kippy are joining the gas
digital family baby and we could not be
more excited yeah guys this is [ __ ]
awesome and but don't worry not much is
changing if you listen to the podcast
it's still available free wherever you
listen the most 15 the most recent 15
episodes are available free on iTunes on
YouTube wherever you listen to podcasts
but the catalog of our you garbage will
be available on gas digital network.com
but don't you worry your little garbage
hearts
ladies and gentlemen because if you go
to gas digital network.com and use promo
code a yg got you big man talk to me I
get you a 14-day free trial and you'll
save a dollar 50 a month combo long as
you're signed up it's gonna be uh whoo
you'd be crazy not to sign up for that
that savings right there and in this
economy we can all use to save a couple
of bucks so spend it wisely folks not
only do you get the catalog of a yg you
also get the past catalogue of Legion of
skanks of real last podcast I believe
you mate with Michael Bisping Irish
goodbye Irish goodbye you get all the
shows on the network it's gonna be
[ __ ] worth it guys sign up use promo
code or a yg don't be a piece of trash
and gang don't forget to check out the
live stream every Tuesdays and Fridays
at gas digital network.com if you want
to watch it in HD high quality sign up
for the network you will not regret it
those live streams will be out three
days before everybody else gets to see
them so you're the first one to smell
the garbage baby sign up today
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is ru garbage the show
where we sit down with your favorite
comedians and fun if they grew up classy
or if their absolute trash I'm your host
a trolli coming at you on a beautiful
Sunday evening here in Bluebell
Pennsylvania got some baby back ribs on
the smoker
my co-host whose rude he's recently back
in New York City he's back holdin down
the heights letting them know let me
tell you something gang next time you
reach her for a best pal make it a
kippie all right he's a good kid we all
love him give it up for Kevin James Ryan
everybody hey gang happy to be here
thanks for listening back in New York
City for a we got in about six minutes
ago I tried hanging my air conditioner
fell out my four-story window things are
going good it's a little wobbly the duct
tape holding an air conditioner who
knows guys if you haven't already please
make sure your rave reviews subscribe on
iTunes full of video available on
youtube check it the [ __ ] out yes sir in
gang I can't tell you how excited we are
to have our very special guest here
today if there was ever a very special
episode of are you garbage I would have
to say this would be it cuz this might
get a little sad this might pull on the
heartstrings a little bit okay gang
Hulme from the affected podcast he's a
Philadelphia original I'm talking Raven
lounge 16th and Sampson going back to
when Moses wore short pants we had a
couple of beers in our day me and this
kid ladies and gentlemen give us a nice
big round of applause and give it the
[ __ ] up from
- Ryan schoener everybody thank you
ladies and gentlemen I'll be the lady
how is that painting and blood behind
you just yeah you know dude that's dog's
blood the blood of the father did when
did you move into the hotel from the
shining
yo by the way after I corrected my
family that's it exactly
for the listener okay if you're not
watching the video of this Shaner has a
lamp behind them that has two sockets
but there's only one bulb in one socket
and that right there is garbage no no no
no no no there's two bulbs one's a blue
bulb it's a black light for when I get
down on my [ __ ] couch did you have a
black light yeah who are you quagmire
what do you in your are you in your
living room or bedroom oh my god this
guy's got a [ __ ] tarantula going now
dude this is uh this is my living room
he tells his route he tells his roommate
when the blue lights on wait a couple of
dumb down dude get the blue light
special dude it looks like you live in
an aquarium with that guy sorry yeah
start eating crickets that's actually
how I keep warm in the wintertime [ __ ]
schoener got out again god dammit
now I legs in the base now when you said
don't come down tell me you live in the
basement no no no I I've been here for
like almost a decade
yeah yeah so basically this is like my
roommate I mean I've had four roommates
I think in the last band you're on the
lease it's your apartment yeah it's it's
my place yeah definitely it's a house
it's a three it's a three-bedroom house
in South Philly this guy making a name
for himself that's what I'm trying to do
I try to keep that light on so all the
[ __ ] know when they come in sure that
it's already that's already a crime
scene you don't got to worry about the
stains cuz you see them in here we [ __ ]
okay buddy we're so happy to have you on
the pod we're so happy to see ya tell us
the story
the
origin story of Ryan schoener she won't
like a power plan or something didn't
you did I know you did me for the
listener me and Shana were [ __ ] hike
back in the day there was a lot of beers
so a lot all weirdness rolling around
down yes I I grew up I grew up five
miles outside of a nuclear power plant
in Spring City Pennsylvania Oh spring
city that sounds a made-up that's you
that's like the town and stranger things
yeah don't don't let it they're like
there's a lot of Springs here
apparently Spring City again I learned
this in the in the 1800s it was supposed
to be like a destination spot for
Philadelphia socialites to go there so
there's a lot of big houses gotcha in
the main street of Spring City but like
they just got turned into stupid
apartments is like no one wants to come
there it was a [ __ ] below the water
table and then there were natural
springs everywhere in the city so every
place they built got [ __ ] up within
like a month of them building it so now
the crazy thing the crazy thing is now
because of the nuclear power plant Oh
every building that has a occupancy of
above 90 has to be made into a fallout
shelter Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] our
water table dude oh man it's gonna be
it's it's crazy I remember that was a
that was the craziest part to it like
when 9/11 happened and the plane crashed
in Shanksville everyone's ago my god
everyone got worried because you know
Shanksville is pretty far away from
Spring City but in a jumbo jet going
like five hundred [ __ ] miles an hour
it's not that far away from where the
power plant is so everyone started
getting worried that they were actually
aiming for the power plant like get the
[ __ ] over yourself like spring city's
like that's the target yeah they're just
gonna kill a bunch of schoener scumbags
up there in spring city living well get
them all we'll get them all once every
time you saw Osama bin Laden in the cave
like doing like a video [ __ ] message
to America my dad's in the background
and I'll post her with a knife in his
yeah yeah David Lee got him all day but
you know they um what was the name of
the nuclear power plant
it's the Limerick exelon generating
station it's in Limerick Pennsylvania
which is like I mean Limerick royersford
in Spring City are all the same [ __ ]
thing they're dis out did they pay and
sponsor for everything in your town
because they knew they were [ __ ]
slowly nuking you dude when we got there
the first house we moved into actually
had those mannequins in when they blow
up the testing thing do they really oh I
don't know dude literally so if you're
not from Pennsylvania area like if you
do once you get like an hour outside
Philadelphia things get squirrely quick
so when they built that power plant that
was I think either a year before or a
year after the Three Mile Island
incident happened so when that happened
everyone was like is that gonna happen
here is like no no no there's only two
reactors not three flex seal around the
whole thing it's gonna be fine it's one
guy with that reflective like metallic
tape like you see how I put it on the
side that's fine oh you don't get it and
I don't even know do you have brothers
and sisters yeah I have so my mom has
been married four times her first
marriage she Liz Claiborne now she just
likes to bang dude so the first first
marriage is my older half-brother and
sister my dad is myself and my younger
brother the third marriage no my mom I
think my mom got her tubes tied and the
fourth one she's just not doing it so
you know I only got yeah three siblings
totals so who'd you actually grow up
with uh me and my younger I drew up with
all them I mean they were all in the
same house my mom was like the one who
just took care of everybody
uh-huh but I mean me and my younger
brother were a year apart so we spent a
lot of time together and just ended up
growing this huge almost nuclear hatred
from one another to grow
he was so mad about the amount of times
I almost killed that kid it is so crazy
for the listener Shane is a bit of a
[ __ ] wild card like schism fast and
loose and calm down a lot in the later
years yeah you're in your like mid-30s
you shoot it's not like you're 19
running amok he's not above a sucker
punch I could tell you oh I try to look
everybody in the eye right yeah that's
true he's not he's not above punching
you in the face
I'll look right at you and hit you in
the face and then maybe I'll shake your
hand afterwards I'm a very [ __ ]
handshake type of guy I remember you
almost blew my knee out one time at the
raven wrestling with you yeah you
[ __ ] idiot you came up to me you're
like I played lacrosse mr. Foley got a
best dude I thought you guys were
wrestling and then like Shaner clearly
you pulled it on the defensive quick and
we tried he was pushing it back towards
the stairs and dude it was gonna be a
wrecking ball going down those stairs
those stairs are dangerous to walk down
after a couple of city wines you know
those stairs were death traps dude and
it's like this [ __ ] lummox is coming
at me like I need to wrestle a couple at
times and just like puts on a [ __ ]
singlet these keen old school singlet
and they here only came up to me like
[ __ ] curly let's go poke you in the
eye I definitely I feel like that that
was at the end of the night I definitely
had a couple of Red Bull and vodka in me
yeah I guess you can call a Red Bull he
was the only guy with a Red Bull dealer
[Laughter]
from nice town yeah I was cuz I use the
only person I ever saw have a Red Bull
in a baggie that's so great
Springfield knows beers am i right
did you go out there the Limerick Power
Company will straighten your right arm
rods two rods two rods I'll get up to
holy would be [ __ ] snorting plutonium
and he lived out his spring city or
whatever he's parachuting dopes in his
eyes he's like those isotopes trying to
get back to the future man trying to
wreck my mom in 1955 man oh I would have
made the move on [ __ ] mrs. McFly oh oh
dude get out of here my nose is hot is
Lea Thompson so I'm assuming yours
childhood was like small tasks small
suburban to like you know [ __ ]
blowing up frogs and [ __ ] jumping
bikes knocking over banks
I always said you know growing up there
everyone asks cuz you know you if you
try to explain spring city to people and
they're like confused cuz they're like
well that's not like any town I've ever
heard of them like that's not [ __ ]
nuclear power plants and that's also the
other thing is like you know I grew up
in a very blood rooted town like all my
relatives still live there my brother
lives two doors down for my mom my
sister lives a block away from my mom my
older brother lives one town over all my
aunts and uncles all live in the same is
a question do any of do currently and
we'll get into the questions in a minute
but this this part doesn't do any of
your family members property lines touch
ah very close very close very that's
always when it's like an aunt and uncle
living next to it a grandmother so it's
always bad news let's put it this way
my brother my younger brother came like
he can look out his window and see my
mom's house it's right there so for a
hot meal I mean that's that's a perk
because Kyle don't cook for [ __ ] his
house is his house honestly looks like
the Bates Motel house with like every
like everything just in one room he
never unpacked he's been there for about
like three years and every time you go
over them like I want you doing he's
like what I'm not gonna do none what do
you what do they do what're your
siblings do my older brother he's see
that's the thing my older brother is a
very smart and a stupor
he does he does consulting for a green
energy company okay so he does that and
my sister-in-law his wife is a
kindergarten teacher
okay sister is a major consultant for a
thing called plan Co insanity auga and
her husband my brother-in-law works with
I think he's like a physical therapist
okay these are good job was thinking
like squirrel trapper no no that's the
only reserved for colonize these are all
these are all meth fronts what are you
taking a green energy company Kyle Kyle
owns his own pest control company but
he's got a sledgehammer and that's all
he does he just goes overs like those
raccoons got to go don't worry don't
worry
and y'all solve cocktails to get the
cockroaches in your mom is remarried now
yeah yep
so growin growing up was there sports
was there I mean the only was the life
like growing up in Spring City well I
mean like as a kid do wanna [ __ ] what
does a kid do on a Saturday night in
Spring City well 13 so when would you
say when you're 13 mm-hmm oh when you're
13 you break into the old asylum
Pennhurst and you go in there you drink
you find anybody whose parents basement
or garage you can get into where they
have like a refrigerator or cooler in
the garage you just steal [ __ ] from
there and then the other thing is
sitting outside of a liquor store just
sitting and waiting for anybody for to
make like hard eye contact with you and
you just hold up money and your third
hmm yeah yo the Wild West out there man
these kids are [ __ ] hillbilly this is
these ain't city folk all right Italy
you're married settle down dude first
off I know three guys right now who met
their wives when they were in ninth
grade
no Seamus no sham so it's like when
you're when you grow up out there you
got two options you can either be bored
or you can be in trouble and the whole
thing is never be bored you just [ __ ]
around super hard and you know you break
into places that like you know you could
definitely tell in Spring City and roars
forward and Limerick that was a place
where like they thought they were
ride the coattails of Pittsburgh with
steel they were like oh we're gonna get
some of this and they build all these
[ __ ] buildings and then nothing
[ __ ] happened you just go in and you
break [ __ ] a lot you steal from the
asylum you find like weird artifacts
they crazy people take well I mean in
the the asylums shut down in 1980 oh so
when that shut down in 1980 they took a
lot of the people who were like too far
gone and they put them in Norristown
state hospital and then the rest of the
people they just let out in Spring City
as Ward's of the state
so they would just walk around the town
there was a guy named Eddie who would
eat anything for a dollar name's Foley
we may get eat [ __ ] all the time 50
cents they give me a shoe some hot sauce
dude I watched that guy Eddie honestly
eat an entire bowl full of dirt for a
buck you sound like a really good kid
[ __ ] Boy Scout over here so growing
up your mom was remarried it wasn't your
dad but there was a dad in the house
right your stepdad and and the three
kids well my older brother Mark got
kicked out when he was 13 Oh kids
getting kicked out of the house yeah
yeah round thirteen fourteen you got
kids where was he supposed to go to live
with his dad okay that's different but
that was because my brother I think he
got busted for smoking pot and then my
stepdad wasn't having it and my older
brother was like [ __ ] you I'm leaving
and he just like left one day I was like
holy [ __ ] and then he went down some
little Rambo [ __ ] right there in the
woods oh no you just like got busted and
that was another thing is like that was
the first time I ever like he was
smoking pot but I never wanted you like
smoked pot at all but like I remember
like other kids we like we would Huff
[ __ ] like hideousness all the time yeah
we have we don't know we have we have
gas once or twice but you know was big
was dust off well that was like later
that what that came in high school but
it's crazy though this is
true [ __ ] uh when I was in I think like
fifth fourth or fifth grade this kid
named Mike Bieber in my hometown died
because he was huffing butane in his
shed and then he was so disoriented he
tried to light a cigarette and he burnt
himself from the inside out and he died
now his parents were so distraught by
this and they didn't know what I like
about huffing or anything like that so
they decided to have an open casket
funeral for him to try to scare kids
straight and my sister went and she to
this day says it's the most horrific
thing she's ever seen in her [ __ ]
life dude new city what spring city is
something else
yikes let's go to a sponsor real quick
[Laughter]
that's the other thing too man is like I
grew up in a town where like you you
talk about like what was it a year ago
like I'll go there every now and again
just to see what's going on I mean the
last time I was there was for my [ __ ]
dumb dad's funeral but before that I
went back hit like on Thanksgiving I was
like hey what's been going on with the
town cuz this is new and this is new and
I was like oh nothing's been really
going on oh except that like a week we
had two crazy suicides what are crazy
suicides and one of them was that a
pregnant 21 year old threw herself in
front of a freight train at the Maine
crossing and royersford and like just
died immediately and then a little
relation and bounced back from that one
oh no she got off it was gonna be touch
and go for a couple of days of corner
bazooka to blow her head off people are
very resilient out there man plutonium
in their blood my dad lost his foot when
he was 14 on it's that same moving train
I think you just [ __ ] you just keep
going you don't have any other [ __ ]
choice but anyway Christ I think a week
what's new what's new is hey we got a
Panera Bread double-suicide
but there's everything mom-and-pop out
there
some of some of it is and some of it
like that's all thing is it was so
podunk that like when we got an Outback
Steakhouse people if we made it we
[ __ ] made it now like that was like
dude that Outback had to have made like
a hundred grand that first weekend 800
buds everybody was there really even
came I think we were using wooden
nickels from the fire club like you go
dude yeah I bring my own ketchup I don't
know if you guys know there's no trowels
in the bathroom the piston where the
[ __ ] is that
I don't want nobody looking at my dick
white achingly it's [ __ ] dude that's
also another thing there's a couple
places I've been there whether they had
the the troughs to piss in instead of
like urinals or whatever oh yeah that's
someone has dude with so much but some
this is dude I was like who is so
homophobic someone glued particle board
in between the parts just so no one can
look at each other's dicks it like what
was happening in this bathroom lot of
PGP key yeah that's what the bathroom is
for a little pinky people check out the
competition see what's going on you see
who's swinging the meat bat harder dude
after you separate the men from the boys
those open troughs I'll say that
honestly that's that's how you figure
out who the radiation affected more like
I was five dicks in a bathroom i santa
toga what's up with that face got an eye
I swear to God okay
I went to Home Depot this morning with
my mother and I got to thinking about
this now when you mention the Outback
Steakhouse it triggered my mind it seems
to me like nowadays a lot of shitty
towns what happens is is they put a
highway through it right you know
talking about where there's those big
stretch of like serious I weigh like two
lanes on one side there's a medium and
all that [ __ ] we got it all in median
what I say mediodía mouth and body you
haven't been a medium
you should that word should be taken out
of your vocabulary okay but when they
put don't like you know they put the
Walmart they put the outback they put
the Chevrolet they put like all these
huge corporate places all along that
when you drive through a town like that
you're like yeah this is [ __ ] it's
it's that's all they have out there is
it's the biggest thing that they keep
building is like strip malls and
cemeteries that's the that's their bread
and butter is like you know let's put
another coals here and then adjacent to
that there will be a necropolis it's
[ __ ] crazy cuz nobody leaves there
nobody leaves they just like keep
breeding and then they die and there's
like well where can we go like that
t.j.maxx is on fire right now that's
where you go I just found the new brand
at Walmart which I'm sure it with you
guys cuz you're too skinny minis but
it's the brand called George at Walmart
I ain't wearing anything called George
buddy I just dropped 160 bucks at
Walmart George with a J or George with a
G that would be classy with a J but nah
I thought it was George with a J with an
ohm loud over the Oh like your CH George
yes george foremans clothing line Jorge
nah man's [ __ ] awesome yeah I love
all that stuff I know that's garbage but
I love like that time Kippy me and you
talk about all the time Altoona doing
shows and we went to that [ __ ] TGI
Fridays together living unit
Pennsylvania were putting in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jack Daniels sauce that day but
I flew my [ __ ] air back you want you
want to talk about some trash talk about
clothing I remember when I was in high
school and two of my friends died in a
car accident
and everyone everyone had to go to this
case you're like the [ __ ] Grim Reaper
dude everybody ready
what are you Christine the car even get
me sorry too dude
so when they died I remember like
everyone was like devastated and like I
remember I was gonna go to the funeral
but I have anything aware and I went to
the Ross that was in my hometown
so many of my there like buying buying
funerals and court appearances that's
how raw state business in Spring City
that's how it goes small claims court
[ __ ] it out the study dude that's how
you get there dude not going to a
funeral because you had nothing to wear
I want to pay my respect but I don't
have a baron that's another thing man
when my dad died my trash if you would
do that if there as a man you should be
able if there's a wedding or a funeral
tomorrow you should be able to do a suit
no not me I was elated I was the only
person at my dad's funeral that was
dressed like they were going to a
funeral everybody else was there for a
[ __ ] Superbowl party look like he
worked there that's dude they were
tipping home dude let me get two up
front by the body what's that over there
that Tommy shake that's crap I'll never
understand people that wear like sports
golf Analia too nice Mayans my younger
brother and he is younger easy
my younger brother my younger brother
his father's funeral I [ __ ] you not
showed up with the just the front of a
shirt tucked in a chain wallet and skate
shoes and jeans with a rip in the knee
this is for his dad's funeral that's
crazy
no I what do you think goes through
their head is it like look at all these
other suckers dressed like adults or
like or does he think he fits in that's
what he was I I know he was just like
man you know I gotta get dressed up for
something this this shirt dressed up
that's dressed up that's dressed up so
that's where that's where the disconnect
is they think it's a nice piece of
clothing my brother's like you know dad
wouldn't care I'm like it's not even
about that boy you look like you should
be like naughty you should look like you
shouldn't even be allowed in here you
understand
yeah yeah that was everything I could
the phone the morning of the funeral he
was like you know what are we wearing
that's a big one what are you wear my
brother's like what are we wearing I'm
like what are you [ __ ] talking about
dressed like you're going to a dress
like you're going to your father's
funeral Kyle maybe he wanted a match
he's like look why if you got green Zuba
stripes you know I'm wearing a [ __ ]
black ones come you don't wear don't
wear chain wall cuz you know I just got
a new one and I wanted to wear it it's
my thing okay did you go to Ross rye in
the morning to all my way to Ross I'll
pick you up we gotta get close I was
thinking I always thinking more like you
both show up in tuxedos like in
stepbrothers yes that would be preferred
honestly to tell you the truth if Kyle
showed up in a [ __ ] tuxedo no
everyone be like look at Kyle he cleans
up well cleans up well they would think
he's the governor or something
mister Shana Noel oh I should have worn
a monocle at my dad's [ __ ] funeral
yeah that would amaze you mayor of
Spring City char had a power plant
I don't think Spring City has a mayor I
think it's just all police by its yeah I
don't even think they have things that
guy dentist that eats the dirt whatever
Oh Eddie Eddie
dude Randy is a Randy as a [ __ ]
spring city name there Randy young Randy
yeah oh dude Randy and you little Randy
three Randy's one Rudy and there was a
couple Rudy Rudy
I never met a Rudy and Rudy was a
gigantic [ __ ] ginger kid who just
like was Natori was on a wrestling team
of mine he was notorious for [ __ ]
his pants too like that was like his
thing Mulga never met a Rudy I liked
listen gang I think out there we have a
picture painted of what where
we're what we're about together for
better where do you think his answers
what side of the fence they might fall
on well but let's get into some are you
garbage questions with our good pal
from the [ __ ] dick podcast with our good
pal Brian six mr. Ryan Shane er here do
you okay now just for just for the court
records do you think you're garbage no I
think oh yeah I think retainer what with
Rudy and Randi in the chain wallets what
all right
why I would know I think it's garbage
comes with a little level of ignorance I
understand what's going on I don't even
I think I think if you're if you're true
garbage if you're true legitimate
garbage you like my younger brother
prime example yeah he didn't he called
me the day of my father's funeral to ask
what to wear to a funeral for his father
he doesn't get it okay and also I think
I think some of we just had this with we
had Florentine jim Florentine on yeah
and he was actually he's like you know
kind of like a known I don't wanna say
scumbag but like he's rough around the
edges and his behavior was trashing but
his upbringing was kind of classy like
he he's brought up by good stock he's
got good yo don't get me wrong there are
things there are things I do that I'm
like in the middle of them like there
ain't nothing wrong with us and then
later someone be like you know that's
[ __ ] wrong I'm like yeah right
you know you're right all right ain't
wrong on that but I do it because like I
know that if I were to do it in my
family setting nothing would be knowing
that not of course that's what I mean is
like I but then again it's like I also
understand how the [ __ ] world works
sure yeah yeah like there are certain
there are certain parts of me that are
just so [ __ ] and grained that I
can't get and I just would do it if no
one was saying nothing so yeah I would
say we're about to do them right now so
basically what you're saying is that you
came from garbage but now you're not
garbage now you also just expose
yourself because you said there's some
things that you can
avoid we're gonna try to find those
things together right now let's do it
Kevin let's start some of the basics
what was the name of the grocery store
you guys went to janar DS yeah janar DS
that was also employed by some of those
people who were let out of an asylum so
you know he has a manner it's got the
authorities name on it and passes the
test you don't need a doctorate to push
the carts around you know what I mean
it's keep us minorities but there was
also another place we used to go to
called cobs which is still in operation
columns which Kol BS Todd which was a
which was a farmers you should have
stayed at the ginardi Singh have been
moving [ __ ] Hobbs Hobbs still to this
day has the best scrapple I think I've
ever eaten in my entire weight they
grocery show that made their own scrap
it was a farmers market that had a
slaughterhouse on site okay I got you go
no you go I want to throw this curveball
out yet just you know from the from
garbage to not garbage etc etc so it's
kind of a two-part question growing up
and now yeah
when you open a loaf of bread okay
mm-hmm do you put the twist tie back on
it or do you tie the bread bag in a knot
what's your even more do you do the fold
you do the fold
that's the way you [ __ ] do it you
fold you don't pull anything you just
fold the bag over and put put it down
it's a nuisance
[Music]
the bugs could get in it the balls about
what do you bugs you wait up bugs in
your house it's a trash move it is it's
a lazy move it's a lazy move and
debatable I would say that I recycle the
twist ties and let my cat play with them
you know that's I mean thinking son of a
[ __ ] here so so you're telling me you
did that growing up and you do that now
that's a move yeah yeah actually you
know my mom would [ __ ] about not using
twist
but I would just do it anyway okay
that's class she was also like a [ __ ]
you know she was also like a very she
was also a [ __ ] no-nonsense [ __ ]
so it was like I mean he's buying this
bread she wants it fresh you know
she's like if Ryan if it came this way
that's the way it [ __ ] ends up that's
the way it came you put it back on
here's the second part of the question
okay I guess if you go to both you um
did you ever keep bread in the freezer
yeah oh yeah I do that now that's what
most scientists would call trash Garvey
scientists it's really me and Foley okay
she's not just in a kitchen with a
magnifying glass are you talking about
Beekman from Beakman's world you get me
Albert Einstein on the phone he wasn't
putting this bread the freezer here you
want to talk about trash though you this
is this blew my [ __ ] mind I had a
roommate who lived here who would put
and I [ __ ] you not I'd be like this is
the dumbest thing I've ever heard in my
life
she would put garbage in the freezer in
the summertime so bugs wouldn't come in
because if you left it out in the house
flies would come in but she would put
garbage like empty containers of plastic
with food that had food in it in the
freezer and then all of my [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the freezer would end up tasting like
[ __ ] garbage all my [ __ ] duty even
even the pop-tarts I put in the [ __ ]
freezer pop-tarts in the freezer this
kind this guy this guy's coming at me
from all directions I don't know what's
going on why am i why you put pop-tarts
in the freezer yeah yeah what you
talking about let me ask you a question
what we do it when you went to slobs or
whatever it was called but you went to
cobs or the pop-tarts in the freezer
section or where they out on a counter
now they no no no first of all there
box wrapped in tinfoil in a vacuum
sealed bag what's the freezer gonna do
anyway anyway the fries this is why put
pop-tarts in a freezer wall turn me
their batteries company no one it's a
it's a delicious frozen treat when you
eat it it's very refreshing and good to
a lot of people don't know if you take
s'mores pop-tarts and put them in the
[ __ ] freezer then take them out
microwave over three seconds put some
[ __ ] chunky peanut butter on the back
you got yourself in a class [ __ ]
dessert
this guy might be brass I don't think
it's great he's three three you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you get them you
freeze them up you break them up put
them in a bowl of [ __ ] with some milk
and eat some [ __ ] pop-tart cereal and
it is [ __ ] delightful huh
cuz I've heard of keep week week we used
to keep the cupcakes in the fridge yeah
dude any treat colder is good I'll give
you that anybody listening to this or
anybody watching this I swear to [ __ ]
Christ
bye s'mores pop-tarts put them in the
freezer take them out put peanut butter
on the back of it microwave it for three
[ __ ] seconds and blow your I swear to
[ __ ] god I swear to god Wow
alright you had me up until I mean if
you're making cereal out of [ __ ]
pop-tarts you slipped up somewhere that
move go get a thing of Cocoa Krispies or
fruits or something that's good man
I'll give you the first two you might
have got you that that's classy
you're making a snack better hey I'm
definitely gonna take a look into that
I'm telling you later I'm telling you
right now you're gonna put my I swear -
I swear [ __ ] dude you're gonna you're
gonna send me a text message you don't
wake or whatever you're gonna be like I
don't know what the [ __ ] I've been doing
I swear to god a week where you gonna be
at nine o'clock tonight if you think
he's not gonna [ __ ] currently throw
his [ __ ] toaster strudels in there
you're nuts
all right holy [ __ ] i dude that threw me
through a [ __ ] loser what in the [ __ ]
okay were you a Bagel Bites or a pizza
rolls family oh man
so it's funny any time we wanted to have
like bagel bite
my mom thought it was stupid she's like
I don't understand why the [ __ ] you
would buy Bagel Bites however my mom and
this is again another thing my mom would
do she would take she would buy
everything bagels are like poppy seed or
like plain and then she would make her
own pizzas with them in the in the oven
and we'd have those for like bagel pizza
night buddy that's class that's a class
move if you're full making a meal that
you would typically buy frozen yeah
that's a home run
yeah we'd have those we never those a
bunch I've only come across this once in
my life and let me tell you something
I've done sleepovers with the best of
them
I specifically remember this Robbie
Hutchinson's mom one day
breaking out some Bagel Bites she said
you guys want Bagel Bites and we were
like yeah and when I was like eh let's
go get him I walked into that kitchen it
smelled that toaster oven going I was
like that can't be [ __ ] note and
fresh ones [ __ ] made them fresh dude
there was one time my mom made those
bagel pizzas and like we that was like a
thing to she was like she was like what
do you guys want pepperoni but I was
like yeah he was doing Pat this brunch
doing supreme hold on he's like she's
like you want pepper who didn't have a
pepperoni my mom used [ __ ] venison on
the [ __ ] bagel pizzas you know
[ __ ] insane er what the [ __ ] man just
keeps going right into a line crossing
over it [ __ ] a roadkill bites come on
man I got dinner in 20 listen listen
here there was one time my dad so my
[ __ ] dad was a he was a trophy pirate
I don't know if you guys know what that
is sounds like something they do it the
why though I'll tell you that yeah he's
got major peewee hockey trophies in his
eyes like I did this know uh we would
drive around if we were ever driving by
some of them we saw like a deer on the
the road that had like certain points on
the antlers he would go and saw the
heads off for the antlers off of the
deer on the side of the road
sure but every now and again there would
be like a fresh kill and what like I
remembered there was a time the DOE that
we saw wasn't it wasn't huge it was
until I got Gigantor back he dropped it
off at a friend's house and then left
and we didn't see it and then like a
month or two later I remember my dad
gave us both beef like jerky in like a
[ __ ] plastic bag and it was like
seasoned with all this [ __ ] weird
like McCormick's rub and [ __ ] and it was
amazing he's like yeah her dad oh we
found on the side of the road
that's the turkey from that though I
mean what kind of life or you know
that's that's super common and venison
venison bites so here great weight
venison is amazing
wait everybody shut up that is not
[ __ ] comments and second of all you
come from a life where your mom makes
homemade [ __ ] eats a bagel zone your
dad's picking up roadkill yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy dude talking about Romeo
and Juliet I'm Jesus to do anymore
do you like venison Kippy oh I would
I don't like it off the side of the road
I'll [ __ ] tell you that's a if it's a
if it's a fresh kill
it's a waste of my only water where we
gotta talk about this show you know I
didn't know you were roadkill eaten
people Kevin if you check a deer's
[ __ ] on the side of the road and
there's no flies or maggots in it that's
like a [ __ ] in less than an hour
honey I don't care if he [ __ ] died
and if there's a ladybug that's good
luck yeah that's something else but see
I mean but then again you have homemade
like jerky I'm not supposed to hold I'm
saying you're finding it on the side of
the road what would you want it yeah
it's got yeah no that's the definition
of clean living dude that's from Earth
who came up with clean living adding
tween women
[Laughter]
Wow
tomato tomahto dude this is nuts hey
listen if you want venison first of all
you live in the [ __ ] sticks it ain't
hard to get our hands on some venison
you don't see me picking it up off the
side know what I'm saying is what I'm
saying is sometimes you see a [ __ ]
like say you're driving to the bowling
alley as we were that day I'm not even
with you but sure okay go in the
Limerick bowl sure and then my dad's
like Arama
he's like holy [ __ ] and I remember a
stopping in my younger brothers like
what are we doing is a god damn it I
remember him going out there like
pulling it by a time legs he's like aah
and he's like picking up the tail
looking at his ass I was like ah Thomas
I mean putting the [ __ ] band saying
he drove for a good two to three miles
out of her way to get from the bowling
alley to stop at his buddy Shepherds
house to drop point I would hope so I
wouldn't hope you left it in the car
with no flavor bowling a wicked game I
got a turkey going on in the dead deer
back let's go
I mean about a hot streak turn on the AC
in the car yeah ice that puppy down in
the trunk let's do it you stop at a
[ __ ] a wall on get him that igloo ice
and just dump it on top hey what do you
got this is this is a [ __ ] whacky
episode I knew it baby I know it I'm
dude I don't even know where to go on my
questions I'm telling come over here
flipping through papers I don't know
what's going on here's something all
right
it's an everyman question right here you
go on to the store you get beer you
bring it back you put it in the fridge
do you leave it in the six-pack or the
case or do you take them out and stack
them up individually so the six-pack I
have here I just I I just throw the
six-pack in there I don't [ __ ] take
I taught you yourself you get a six-pack
you're looking to get [ __ ] hammered
alone think about some [ __ ] wonder where
it all went wrong listen to some [ __ ]
Pink Floyd [ __ ] take the only time
you only leave it don't take the only
time I will take beer out of like a case
or a six-pack or anything like that if I
know I'm gonna have chicks over other
than that I don't give a [ __ ] have
chicks over woody what do you
McConaughey relax
who do you the Fonz I have chicks over
I'll take it out and make it look like I
might you know be a little bit classier
there do you want to you want to hear
trash I went down to my mom I could just
see them get into a fight the next
morning as she's walking out the door
I took the beer out of the six-pack for
you what more do you want you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I went down to my mom's shore
house this weekend and I reached I
opened up the fridge and I see 12
package twisted DK and so I reach in for
one and there's only one left in the box
and the box is still in there it's like
you're like reaching all right you reach
in the back I'm like did any did any of
you ever have the [ __ ] dick hit and
my dad was like notorious for this
sounds like why do you and I don't to
this day none of it made sense and he
never really gave me an explanation but
he would do it all the time were you or
any anybody you know if you drank a
six-pack of like especially cans in a
case after you were done you'd put the
can back in in the case itself so you
could throw the whole case out but you'd
still do it while I was in in the fridge
that's weird that's weird I've never
done though you got like half stank beer
and the [ __ ] seems like the [ __ ]
mind of a man that does that I think
that's like borderline insane but when I
brought that up to him and I told that
to somebody else like yeah my dad does
that same [ __ ] like someone was very on
board with that same type of like wow
there was in another spring city in
Orwell forcing us of course it was of
course was someone from in town I don't
know I think that's pretty trashed but I
get it what I don't get it explain it to
me I don't know it's like you know
I mean I do this that's why I'm saying I
get it I leave the cracked eggs in the
in the carton and put them back oh you
are a [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
cracked eggs all day are you kidding me
[ __ ] Wow quack eggs yeah do you use the
burner
no you just don't want to dribble it you
don't want to drill dribble it all over
the counter crack it right there and put
it right back it also depends on where
it depends on where the trashcan is for
me it's far so I'm dripping on the floor
every time and I'm I'm crying with
doesn't anything like you were they
wouldn't okay you dumb [ __ ]
do you do you have the styrofoam or the
cardboard case it depends
typically styrofoam okay so when there's
how many eggs are the like he ever like
switch them around into the egg math for
like [ __ ] you know even weight
distribution in the [ __ ] carton a
little bit you got okay
so if you do that you can rip it in half
and throw the whole [ __ ] thing away
you [ __ ] dumbass sure I'll give me
that I'm not saying it's right I'm not
trying to push my views on you in a
grocery store for seven years I worked
in Bluebell we're [ __ ] Foley's from
so Jesus I know what the [ __ ] going do
work in a grocery store that's that's a
that's a blemish in the file wait what
what yeah I worked at one too what
department Oh produce produce can go
either way
well you guys are all right if you
worked in the meat if you worked in the
meat or the deli those dudes were deli
Maywood high-end they would they could
get you coke no they're actually the
worst [ __ ] Department honestly in the
entire [ __ ] one was the bakery the
bakery [ __ ] [ __ ] who worked in
there were [ __ ] total [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time but when they redid so I
worked for super fresh so when they they
fired a bunch of people and then they
redid the union so the whole store
became the same union for a little bit
the seafood guys the meat guys in the
bakery people were all the sit like all
different unions so you
couldn't work in their department so
once they consolidated everything you
could work in every department just to
save time because they were laying off
so yeah I got you know I worked in the
[ __ ] meat department for a little bit
saw a guy cut his [ __ ] finger off on
the [ __ ] meats all which was [ __ ]
where he did you're the Grim Reaper it's
amazing you're like you're like final
destination
you know what I'm I feel so town okay
right now going through a bad time
yeah my cat has cancer I just found out
like two days ago
I'll congratulations Jesus I know it's
not good well start a GoFundMe get it
going they told me it was they told me
it was uh non-negotiable I don't think
you negotiate with cancer listen this
cancer is pressing a high number knows
you get out of here I'll have [ __ ] you
know Crazy Eddie eat something of yours
that's terrible I'm sorry it's a bummer
it's a bummer but let's switch anyway
yeah yeah you have a slip-and-slide
growing up yeah we did we also we also
wait what made we had a homemade one
made out of a couple of tarps cuz like
what age did you do that though wait
yeah hold on man you're all over the
place yet you had the slip and slide you
should have stopped at the slip and
slide now I find that using construction
materials so you had the proper branded
aisle brand it like a so we had a new
member do you remember that like Kevin
you're around the same age as me mm-hmm
you remember in the night do you
remember death alley rally do you
remember that at all what was that that
was the wily coyote like [ __ ] Warner
Brothers like slip and slide it like
they had all the things on it right it
had [ __ ] like when you went when you
went through the end it was like a big
splash to bat the like a big pool yeah
it was like a trip down yeah yeah so we
had like you know a neighbor had one of
those felt like we would use that let's
go say okay so I got the [ __ ]
tricked-out no brand slip and slide
no this way if Kyle and I ever got
anything name-brand for like our
birthday or anything like that
I mean I mom she worked at a geriatric
home
making some pretty good money um but my
dad if he ever gave us anything that was
like name-brand
we'd like later on my mom was like you
know where he got that from stole it all
or had a guy with some sticky fingers oh
man all the [ __ ] time
there was like my dad at one point in
time was living on mic I'm gonna say
maybe thirty dollars a week he was he
was in bad shape bad shape but like
every Christmas we would have the newest
gaming console I'm like how the [ __ ] you
afford dude dude that's not garbage you
gotta get it done mm huh there was one
time the PlayStation we got Kyle and I
got a place like the first PlayStation
in 1990 [ __ ] six we got a Playstation
but it wasn't in a box it was wrapped in
a teach some kids blood on it it's a
property of Rudy it was he's like you
know Eddie you'll do anything for a
dollar I over the market yeah no we uh
when we were so low keep down the street
from us had that and then I remember
like we were bitching that we didn't
have anything like that now our front
yard was this shitty it wasn't a shitty
patch a [ __ ] land but it was like
definitely there were rocks in it
all over the [ __ ] place sure so we
were like well we can't do it here but
behind us behind my house was an
abandoned Factory so like on the other
side Factory was a gigantic hill and
like we were talking about like oh man
we should like try and find some and
then in the fact we were break into the
factory all the time we found these
[ __ ] like big tarps and we were like
oh these are perfect and we put them on
the side of the hill and then like we
didn't have any water so Kim yeah
[ __ ] do so this kid went home and
like we did like a bucket line all the
way down throwing buckets of water on
these [ __ ] tarps just so one after
the other could do it and then his other
kids like you know if you use soap you
don't have to really [ __ ] do anything
with water so then we [ __ ] dude this was
like a week operation like
a week all a stream city shut down to
get this [ __ ] dirtbag slip-and-slide
Yui built this slip and slide and then
we saved up money to go to the hardware
store to get like a big like industrial
like big thing like Jergens or like
whatever like soft soap anything and we
just put it all over and we were doing
that for a while and like kids were
getting super [ __ ] up one kid broke
his leg yeah kids up on that kind of
stuff
Jesus Christ watch this this is some
kind of episode these guys all over the
map um have you ever microwave bacon yes
and then the kid died no I microwaved I
I liked Mike i microwave eggs a lot too
you do what wait I'm sorry what Mike
doin eggs so how about this
listen up here i'ma tell you this right
up listen up so what you do you know you
can't Church this up dude there's no
reason I see my kid and I can start with
a little time all right little basil
little Rosalina be your dog that's what
you do what you do is like when you get
Uncle Ben's Minute Rice listen when you
get Uncle Ben's Minute Rice you might go
wave that for the 90 seconds that goes
in there then you take an egg and you
beat that up in a like ceramic bowl you
put that in there you microwave that for
about nine you dump the rice in there
you beat it up there you have like
[ __ ] basically like fried rice with
egg in it
that's [ __ ] dope cut up a couple of
hot dogs throw that in there microwave
that for a little bit welcome back to
cooking with garbage right I'm telling
you right now dude I'll telling you you
there's no circumstance you should put
your baby in an egg it takes 90 seconds
to make on the pan nice sometimes your
gas is shut off
sometimes your gas is shut off far
enough gentleman's point sometimes your
gas is shut off Kevin I'll give you the
rice I'll give that to you
I'm going
I'm gonna give you that one all right my
mom's like just put straight eggs in the
thing with and she's dynamite but for
herself she has a little contraption I
just do it in the microwave it's fine
yeah if you put if you take if you take
the rice mix it in with it yeah I see
when I see the rice is a little
different because then it's an
ingredient till I understand that it's
not you're not just microwaving the
[ __ ] six pack of eggs and you know
that's insane and calm people do you
leave garbage mom does it maybe to one
of the time maybe to mama all right
probably you got one I just got one more
I got well I got I got I got two or
three more maybe um have you ever owned
a lizard or a snake oh yeah
well you sold them you've had to have so
sometime a reptile kind of guy yeah you
weren't we weren't allowed to have any
uh my mom was like really against that
she was all about like taking in strays
though she's all about taking in strays
a lot and I remember I found this
[ __ ] snake in my backyard and I like
put it in a big jar and like I poked
holes in the top of the [ __ ] like
thing for the snake and I put some grass
and [ __ ] in there it wasn't like it was
about maybe like a foot and a half long
yeah but like I put it I didn't want my
mom to find it so I put it there was a
hole in my wall in my bedroom so I put
the snake in there and every now and
again I would like try and feed it mice
but like it was a it was a gardeners
nurse so I didn't so I didn't know and
then maybe some venison no no I forgot
about the snake in the jar in the hole
in my wall forget about a snake in a jar
that you put in your wall that's insane
to me you would have a hole in a wall
where you keep things what dude what
Baker did you have going on in your life
that you forgot about the snake in the
wall what happened to the snake well I
forgot about it and then I smell that oh
man a couple of months went by and I was
like what the [ __ ] smells in
room and like my mom came in she's like
what is that what is that and then like
later I remember like it just like
started to like go away like it just
didn't like it smell anymore
totally forgot about it was until we
were moving out and then same wall that
I was putting putting magazines a porno
in the same hole my wall I was just
putting the porn on top of the [ __ ]
like I started pulling out my god oh my
god look at all these [ __ ] hustlers
and then I was like what the [ __ ] is
this and I blow up there's a liquefied
snake and my ace in a Hellmann's jar he
[ __ ] all that had been there for like
who the [ __ ] knows how long
who at least it was a miracle with your
Hellmann's family I thought miracle it
was like salad dressing my older brother
loved Miracle Whip I got I think I got
two more anyone in your family have leg
tattoos yeah my younger brother does
what is it it's a it's a skeleton
ripping out of the back of his calf it
sounds like it's gonna artistic flair to
it yeah what oh no you got that I think
he got that like a week after he came
back from Afghanistan he was like trauma
winced older brother younger brother
younger brother cuz got the guy you've
been [ __ ] on all the time you tell us at
the end he's a goddamn veteran no he's
not a veteran listen listen listen
so what a lot of people don't know is
that when Obama pulled all the troops
out of like no boots on the ground in
Afghanistan what a lot of people don't
know is that when he pulls all the
troops out because of the contingency
that happened in the first Persian Gulf
War yeah we don't leave any
installations there because they will be
used against us because the Persian Gulf
War the second round in Afghanistan Iraq
Pakistan oh man all that [ __ ] was so
unpopular everyone hated
we had US forces over there because of
that rising death toll so he pulled all
the troops out of the [ __ ] goddamn
desert now if he pulls all the troops
out of the [ __ ] desert
who is gonna break down all those
installations I'll tell you who no well
yeah Kyle devilicus international he was
a National Guardsman so what they did is
they held a lottery this has never
talked about they held a lottery and
certain National Guard's troops were
then flown the [ __ ] over to a goddamn
sandbox for over a year to break down
installations and send them back that's
still a veteran man he was in [ __ ]
harm's way
debatable no that's he was in the [ __ ]
you're gonna be brothers over here
[ __ ] on you ha ha ha drinking
[ __ ] and keeping the six-pack in the
beer in the six-pack look I'm proud to
be an American where at least I know I'm
free and I won't forget my snake in your
wall all right I think I just got one
more and then full you can wrap it up um
have you ever been to a Red Lobster
that was my first date really yeah
however first major date I was at 11 I
was in 11th grade pay yourself no no no
I did I pay myself no I money from my
mom
I borrowed $40 from my mom and she
worried
40 bucks I I think my mom's like lobster
that's expensive and she just gave me
money okay
take 16 dollars we went to the Dakotas I
don't think there was a nap I don't
think there was an appetizer at that
date no because well people don't know
is a [ __ ] you at Red Lobster that played
that dead join ain't cheap how many
cheesy biscuits you give me he got balls
no it was an appetizer we went to uh I
think it was like not the shrimp fest
but like the lobster it was sort of like
how is the seafood in Spring City good
they got a good I mean yeah they got a
good Wharf Eddie just pulled it out of
the water yeah
the Schuylkill River runs right through
there
so you get some of the worst cat fit at
which I've also eaten out of the spring
out of so but the way you get around
that let's to get around that no one's
trying to get around that you leave it
in your wall for a couple it just
becomes booze and you drink that up
Shaner I love you buddy
this makes me realize how much I [ __ ]
miss hanging out with you man we gotta
have a pop just not in Spring City I see
convinced all those Hillbillies to give
us their land honestly if you show up
with a fellow board developer they'll be
falling all over if you go up there with
a snap kitchen franchise they'll give
you anything really got no country or no
it'll be like there will be blood oh
dude this is my buddy HW Foley he's also
a snap kitchen man are you trying to
tell me how handsome my fat friend looks
[Laughter]
my friend is fat he'll drink your
milkshake drink it up and then then
fully a fat ass
[Laughter]
I think another Limerick Limerick
bowl-o-rama and beating I want to hear
that KFC is a fault profit tell me
Arby's is better than Wendy's now okay I
feel like drainage I drank your milk
Jay's like I already drank it nobody
last question here before we get out of
here
is did you suck your or did you or
anybody in your family sucks I came out
thanks brother the wrong pause did you
like
you were any member family suck their
thumb oh man alright here's the cherry
on people's teeth all the kid did sucks
the thumb too much so Kyle
sucked his thumb a lot like a lot
however I would suck these two fingers
like a shit-ton that's it oh my let me
tell you something not garbage you're a
lunatic
wow these two who fingers two fingers
that's real I did it for a while that I
had to like weird teeth marks and my
knuckle yeah that's real poor kid on the
porch who should have been in bed an
hour ago
that's a kid who's got a dirt ring
around his neck for sure oh man the one
time Kyle and I like the word the the
dirty is I think Kyle and I ever got we
came home covered in tar one day because
we were building fell in the Tar Pits no
no we were building a tree house and we
found buckets at our and that abandoned
Factory we're like oh we're gonna
waterproof the yeah you need a rubber
roof you know I get it but then we came
home covered in it like all over the
[ __ ] place and then my mom had to use
paint thinner and Ajax to get it so I
get it off of us that was got this poor
woman I've never met her but I mean it
was crazy
and then Kyle had to get rabies shots
which was [ __ ] crazy because he got
bit by a groundhog that we cornered and
tried to like make the [ __ ] here
little guy Ryan shader man you are the
[ __ ] best you are 100% garbage that's
how you know kevin is garbage cuz I had
him fooled with Pop Tarts in a freezer
he was like crazy moves oh we're not
saying we're not we know you listen you
you know we listen we don't need to tell
any tales out of school you know we're
trash you seen any no I don't understand
how schoener keeps getting these beers
yeah it doesn't get up but there's a new
beer every couple
I have the six-pack with me I took it
out of the [ __ ] bed I thought they
were Miller High Life stare karate heart
no that's just a Corona oh my god folks
just when you thought it couldn't get
any worse he Maurice
they bought six loose beers in and they
put him in a six-pack wow wow wow wow
gang that is are you garbage you guys
are absolutely amazing
Shanna's anything you want the folks out
there to know that they might not
already know anything chuck out I mean
just check out your [ __ ] up podcast
and I'll be at punchline July 12th
really giving uh you know we don't die
from all this rolling the dice I like it
punchline Philadelphia July 12th mr.
Ryan Shane or Kippy you got anything for
him just make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes and subscribe on
YouTube even if you don't watch it just
go subscribe you know juice those
numbers a bit and listen from the bottom
of our heart we want to say we love you
guys very much thank you for supporting
us thank you for supporting the podcast
we have big things coming down the road
we want everybody to stay with us we
love you guys this is our you garbage
that's Ryan Shane er you [ __ ] did
podcast chippy Kevin James Ryan good
night and we love you